we got a lot of young fans that uh that
use craigslist and uh we thought we'd
maybe once again help out people in our
audience
make a sale or connection
by showing some of their craigslist ads
right here on the show i'm gonna do this
for you
that's a nice thing to do
let's check out the first one
here we go
looking for romance ladies then look no
further than the back seat of my used
kia sportage
here we go next
retired gym teacher seeks kids who will
still let him yell at them
[Music]
for sale
the glasses my dad wore to work at
hewitt-packard in the late 70s
[Applause]
[Music]
those are fantastic
those are fantastic glasses pass those
forward i'm going to want to wear those
before the uh the show ends missed
connection
you sitting in the park me sitting in
the park okay i wrote this to myself
[Applause]
[Music]
next like smooth jazz then i'll come
over and beat the crap out of here
[Music]
next up
hey just because i have dreadlocks
doesn't mean i'm selling weed okay weed
for
it took a sale of convincing
please help i'm a child's doll come to
life
life coach for hire i don't have a
computer or phone right now long story
but if you leave a note at the otp on
pico i'll get right back to you
moving on
disc
discount candy for sale cheap prices on
great knockoff candy i got all your
favorites one musketeer eminence tracks
star blast vegetable chews
and finally
kiss my stuffs all my stuffs please to
kiss it my stuff says clean and no
disease and very much i can kiss your
stuffs too my english no good so to make
clear sex
i must have those
where are those glasses
i want those
[Applause]
can you do glasses mind
those are fantastic
you'll get them back i promise we got a
great show from will and grace in the
tnt series perception emmy award-winning
actor eric mccormick's on the show
[Applause]
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
professional skateboarder
give me this card
and the first person
to ever land at 1080 in mega ramp x
games competition
mitchie bruce goes on the show
ferdinand
what an amazing show we'll be right back
stick around
[Applause]